The length should be 15 feet and the width should be 8 feet. Nice problem
solving for getting that one correct. To start solving, I would draw a
rectangle. We'll have a width here and a length here. A dog run is just an
enclosed rectangular area where a dog can play. This would be a bird's eye view
or looking down from up top, into a dog run. We want to start by working on an
equation for the perimeter and the area. Since we enclosed the dog run using 46
feet of fencing, we know that all of these or these sides added together would
be the perimeter or 46 feet. We have enough concrete to cover 120 square feet.
So the area of this rectangle, in the gray, is 120 feet squared. That's what we
can use for A. Now that we have these two equations, we can start to solve our
system of equations. We want to solve this equation for the length, and then
substitute that expression in here. I've taken this equation and rewritten it
here. We'll divide each of the terms by 2, and then we'll subtract w from both
sides to get 23 minus w equals l. We don't change the equation involving the
area, and now, we're ready to substitute the value of l, here, for 23 minus w.
So after we substitute, we'll have the equation 120 equals the quantity 23
minus w, times w. We distribute the w to each of the terms to get this new
equation. And now, we want to solve this quadratic. We add w squared to both
sides and subtract 23w from both sides to get our new equation. We factor this
quadratic by finding factors of a 120 that sum to negative 23, those factors
are negative 15 and negative 8. This means we set each factor equal to 0, so w
can equal positive 15 or w can equal positive 8. We usually consider the width
to be the shorter side, so the width will be 8 feet, and the length will be 15
feet. And, as a quick check, if we add up all the sides around the rectangle,
we'll get 46 feet, which was our original perimeter. And for the area, if we
multiply the length times the width, we'll have 15 times 8, which equals 120
feet squared. This also checks. This means the dimensions are 15 feet by 8
feet, the length by the width.